hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong my name is mark
ellis and what a special episode we have
for everyone listening or watching today
my co-host jacqueline coley is going to
be joining in just a little bit as is
our very special guest from the hit
podcast medium popcorn which you can
also check out on youtube if you want to
watch it it's brandon collins who's a
big nicholas cage fan and really who is
it we love nick cage because he's a
great actor whether it's in a rom-com an
action movie a heartfelt drama and he
also goes for it in movies that are
really running the gamut from super
fresh like big and moonstruck all the
way down to yeah he's got a couple zero
percenters out there so we're gonna be
talking about all things nick cage
particularly those movies that he has
that are rotten on the tomato meter but
we think maybe rotten tomatoes is wrong
about those flicks one of which is con
air the action smash that was the same
summer as faceoff he got connor then he
had face-off like the next month and so
while faceoff is sitting up there pretty
at fresh 92
conair is rotten at 55 and so now before
we're joined by jacqueline coley and
brandon collins we're going to turn it
over to tim ryan he's our review
curation manager and he's an expert at
all these things here at rotten tomatoes
so he's going to tell us what critics
were saying about conair at the time of
its release i know what i was saying i
really wanted that hair at the time
seemed like a good idea tim what'd the
critics say at the time
normally i want you to give our
podcaster your undivided attention but
given today's subject i want you to
press pause and immediately read dana
steven's fantastic 2010 slate essay the
heat seeking panther which is both
hilarious and insightful in its attempts
to grapple with nicolas cage's
fascinating career no spoilers or
anything but the closest she comes to a
conclusion is this when cage takes on
these outsized b-movie roles stevens
writes i don't believe for a moment that
he is just nodding wearily to his agent
and his accountant i think he's
fulfilling a vision albeit one that
looks inscrutable from the outside of
choosing roles in the kind of movies he
himself loves when it comes to the
critics nicholas cage's filmography
varies wildly his worst reviewed is left
behind from 2014 which is rotten at zero
percent his best reviewed movie is from
last year pig is certified fresh at 97
percent into the spider-verse which
features cage in a fantastic cameo is
also at 97 percent but it's not really a
nicholas cage movie per se also red rock
west from 1993 is at 97 but it doesn't
have as many reviews we're talking about
con air today and it's right smack dab
in the middle it's rotten at 55 on the
tomato meter with 65 reviews though it
does have a 75 audience score so what
did the critics have to say in a rotten
review wade major of box office magazine
wrote the conair falls well below the
stature of its aspirations too often
substituting bombast for believability
before finally plunging headlong into
the ridiculous however in a fresh review
dwayne burge of the hollywood reporter
wrote packed high with explosive action
and loaded with high stakes jeopardy con
air charts a genuinely sound narrative
course although it hits some turbulence
before it hits the cinematic jackpot the
rotten tomatoes critic's consensus reads
conair won't win any awards for
believability and all involves seem
cheerfully aware of it making some of
this blockbuster action outing's biggest
flaws fairly easy to forgive so that's
conair and i think it's worth noting
that they somehow managed to get every
mark and jaclyn in the universe onto
this one podcast
and then somehow managed to let them
take it over
and then somehow managed to stick me
right smack in the middle back to you
folks what a time it was to enjoy action
movies back in the mid 90s fun fact
director simon west actually i'll tell
you what else simon west who directed
conair did
after we have our exclusive interview
with brandon collins and jacqueline
coley joining me right now
[Music]
as promised we are now joined by our
very special guest who jackwood really
does it all stand-up comedy producer
podcaster he's the co-host of medium
popcorn and drunk black history and he's
an active member of the african-american
film critics association brandon collins
when do you get to take a nap do you
have any naps in your day are you just
always busy telling jokes talking movies
it's funny i just started taking naps
but even when i'm taking a nap i'm still
either listening to music or i'm
listening to a podcast like i never my
brain
never stops it's just uh it's it's just
always going man i'm always thinking of
unique ideas or potential shows and it's
it's just the way it's been because i
was you know when i was six years old my
mom put me in front of a tv and just let
me watch tv shows and movies all day and
my brain has just never slowed down ever
since that was
that that kind of seems like
how jaclyn and i came up into the world
too especially with entertainment do you
remember the first time you saw nick
cage the first time that you like
mentally could recognize hey that is a
prominent actor and i think i like this
guy yep and uh inappropriately it was
1997's face-off my mom uh you know i was
a good kid so my mom would take me to go
see r-rated movies with her and i
remember you know the opening scene
where nicolas cage is in the priest
costume and he puts his hand on that
choir girl's butt and i just remember
being like
i know who nick cage is now like this is
disturbing like who is this guy and then
uh yeah been followed his career ever
since jacqueline what's your first nic
cage movie do you remember your your
very first experience with uh with the
cage i think it was actually moonstruck
for me
because this was in yeah it was
definitely moonstruck because this was
still in the like we watched the oscars
every year
situation in my family house so as much
as my mother likes to pretend that this
was not a career she set me forth on i
would be like well those days watching
tcm and the oscars beg to differ but um
yeah i remember moonstruck and i
remember
the the clip that was oftentimes used
for that movie was him with like my head
and i was like oh he's going there huh
and i just i was like this guy's a lot
and then i think i saw valley girl
shortly after that but yeah i think the
very first one for me was moonstruck
yeah so i remember the moonstruck poster
at video update but i i remember the
first time i acknowledged that this nick
cage guy was like an actor it was wild
at heart because i didn't rent it i like
back then i'm just looking for anything
that looked like star wars and so my
sister my older sister had rented wild
at heart this david lynch movie with
nick cage and laura dern it was before i
knew her from jurassic park and like i
just caught glimpses of that movie and i
was like i don't know what adults do
with their free time but i hope mom and
dad aren't doing this because this is
nuts this is crazy that's like how i
feel about every nicholas cage movie
that's what i'm so excited to talk about
because there's very few that goes cage
wizard i'm like that was quiet that was
calm like
you know
it's even mandy which is probably his
most quiet one
in regards to like not calm yeah it's
not calm but it's just like you know
very eerie the whole movie
even that's like cuckoo bananas when
you're watching it you're like oh
nicholas cages is underwear now
screaming with a few lines of dialogue
yes yeah you're still not taking a nap
during something like mandy and what's
interesting about our three picks for
like the first time we really knew this
was nick cage is that those are all
fresh movies now you all went super
fresh moonstruck is 94
face-off is 92 percent while it hard for
me 67
which is one below what i consider to be
not only the maybe the greatest nick
cage action movie but also the second
best action movie the 90s the rock is 68
but let's start talking about some of
these movies that are we're basing our
whole show around is rotten tomatoes
wrong about nick cage flicks because
he's got so many rotten movies some of
which are very fairly rotten he's got a
couple zero percenters that i think
deserve to be zero percent but he's got
a lot of really good stuff that just
isn't redeemed in the critics eyes for
whatever so brandon you have the honor
kick us off here what is rotten tomatoes
wrong about when it comes to nicholas
cage where do you want to start i mean i
want to start the wicker man i think the
wicker man is one of the most fun
viewing experiences of
my life i i i every i was always
surprised and then when i watched the
behind the scenes like extras and stuff
and nicholas cage is doing interviews
i'm like oh this movie was just all like
cuckoo for coco puffs there's no one was
on the level when they were making this
film like um and it just has amazing
sound bites like on on my movie podcast
we do like oh my god
oh my god it's just so good the bees
wait a minute wait a minute he came with
his own drops ladies and gentlemen he
came with his own sound effects brandon
sir you came with it i have to say
you're the first guest to ever do that
and so i have to make sure everyone
knows that was not us
man came prepared i have so many
nicholas cage quotes i mean it's uh yeah
uh so wickerman and then trespass
trespass is my favorite one that i know
like i vehemently believe rotten
tomatoes got completely wrong because
everyone gives it 100 percent even
though they didn't have to and they
shouldn't have and it's just amazing
like joel schumacher directed the hell
out of this weird campy lifetime
thriller with nicholas cage and nicole
kidman as a married couple
it's so crazy it's 11
and the wicker man is 15 so i i guess
like my question here
is
like are we particularly with wicker man
is wicker man actually something that
you feel like is a fresh movie or is it
just something where it's so fun to
watch is it like so bad it's good or do
you think it's actually like a good
movie i think because again i i watched
the like the behind the scenes and the
commentary and stuff i think knowing
what their intention was i actually
think it's a really good movie because
they delivered you agree they delivered
what their their vision was for the you
know the performances and the vibe of
the movie wicker man or trespass because
i have different opinions if it's the
wicker man i do think it was put forth
in earnest i just think that the earnest
was guided by some misguided people
trespass i legitimately don't know like
trespass seems like a movie that they
need to do like an oral history because
it has like a list caliber talent
slumming it and as brian
as brandon quite rightly said
brian perez sorry not that and brandon's
quite rightly said uh
it's it's bad it's so bad it's like
that was a movie that probably was meant
to go to a studio they sold off to
somebody crazy and it just has some
weird story because there's no way
that those people signed up for what
they ended up with does that make sense
yeah there there was a movie that was
that they set out that to make or at
least that is on the page and then it
becomes something very different and and
with the wicker man i i do feel like
they were going they wanted to be as
bonkers as they possibly could um the
movie i don't think was necessarily
marketed that way it was just marketed
as like a straight horror movie so i
remember santa for the first time being
like this is not like
this is just another level of crazy and
not cr because like this movie came out
i think a couple years after the others
you know which is a horror movie that
does the normal horror movie stuff it
builds up and we have creepy reveals and
the wicker man just gets so bonkers for
so many different reasons i don't i i i
don't know if it's fresh but man is it
rewatchable gotta be fresh for what he's
flipping over the kid's mask trying to
find the kid and then uh you know he he
wrote a bear costume it goes up to uh
the woman that recruited him he's like
hey it's me it's just there's so many
crazy moments that's that uh that fell
also though too like what's crazy about
the whole idea of it is it's really
ripping up like it's like that was that
time periods the very first wicker man
like that was that time periods midsomar
that's what it was set up to be was just
this like
oh you've gotten caught up in some stuff
you did not can like you know what i
mean like you don't know what you're
messing with here and you're gonna go
it's gonna spiral out of control with
some very strange white people that are
all committed to the same assignment and
you did not know the assignment and so
in that respect i actually understand
why they went bonkers
i just think i don't know
nicholas cage is not the type of dude
that i think you should tell the movie
is bonkers about i think you should just
tell nicholas cage it's straightforward
because that's what mandy is nicholas
cage is actually fairly straightforward
in that movie and everything around him
is bonkers
and that's what sells it
yeah he's the same one uh willie's
wonderland what's the
yeah the film that just came out uh not
too long ago he's he he plays and
completely straightened everything
around him just madness is that the
color of space one or is that oh no i
know which one to talk about yes um is
the one with the animatronics come alive
yes yes he's done he's it's kind of hard
to do it like um
unbearable weight of massive talent that
was a sundance film that's just now
coming out i saw that there and trust me
when i say like
lordy
y'all just y'all just wait are we having
fun with that jaclyn i mean look that's
one of the reasons why we're celebrating
the the breadth of mr cage's work is
because of this new movie he's got
coming out where it's so meta where it's
just him playing himself for this you
know international gangster is it it are
do are you allowed to tell us how you
feel about that movie so i'm getting
confused prisoners of ghostland is the
one that was at sundance that was the
one that was don't get me excited like
that no unbearable weight of massive
talent
i'm not allowed to say
so maybe i have seen it but i don't
think i'm allowed i literally just
remembered i'm like oh i'm not allowed
to say but
so
next question go to somebody else
i'll bail you out right now because it's
very interesting that brandon is going
into is going wicker man and trespass
early in the show because i feel like
there's a nick cage that we knew
who was like the rom-com guy who would
occasionally do a david lynch movie and
then he had his action star days in the
90s with an incredible trio from the
rock to conair which we'll talk about in
a little bit and then face off and then
wicker man comes out in
2005 i believe and then national
treasure book of secrets 2006 and it
seems like right around that time is
when we started
embracing this new nic cage that was
just so weird and kooky and zany and it
started like it was like we didn't know
when his real life ended and when his
screen life began and then you have
trespass by 2011 and that's the year
after the sorcerer's apprentice which is
i i think unfairly rotten at 40 because
it's such a fun movie and the movie did
like over 200 million dollars worldwide
but the sorcerer's apprentice i remember
being in the theater and being like this
is who this guy is now i know he's got
great performances in him but this is
who this guy is he is just so out of his
mind over the top yet he's still
he's still working within the framework
of the film if that makes sense brandon
yeah he has such an amazing filmography
because he doesn't say no to an
assignment but he always understands the
assignment right like even like his
voice working into the spider verse i'm
like man nicholas cage is a national
treasure like no pun intended i'm like
because on our podcast we frequently
talk about denzel washington to us is
the best actor of all time but then
we'll see nicholas cage movie will be
like
wait a minute
like when i saw the rock i mean
the rock is probably his most serious
like his most
normal like action role but you know the
rock and con air which we'll talk about
in a second because i think that rhonda
males is wrong about that
he just has such amazing range and you
oh you can't help but smile when he's on
screen you just know you're gonna get
something different jack when i've got a
comparison here okay so i'm a huge huge
basketball fan and as we have march
madness then we get into the nba
playoffs nick cage is the player who's
not on the best team he's he's on an
underdog team but he's the guy you got
to put three bodies on him because he
can get hot and like if denzel is a blue
blood like a duke or a kansas or a
carolina nick cage is just that other
team that just showed nick cage's
gonzaga he just shows up and could beat
anybody at any time because he's just
that talented but we just never know
what kind of movie we're gonna get and
so you have these movies like into the
spider verse and i would i would cite
joe as the movie that sort of taught me
that nick cage can still deliver an
oscar-worthy performance any time he
gets out of bed he's capable of doing
that and we saw it again this past year
with pig jaclyn yeah no pig that's the
one i think of mandy used to be that one
too i
i think for me if i'm being really
honest the thing with nick cage is the
fact that he can be with anyone but i
always use this analogy
nick can do what leo does leo can't do
what nick does do you know what i mean
like like like he can play in other
people's court but other people can't
play in his
and there's another actor who i say is
like this um and it's funny that i
mentioned leo because leo is going to be
taking over a role that he originated
and that's mads mickelson mads mikkelsen
is like a modern day renaissance viking
like that dude is on a different level
he can dance like fred astaire and like
given the right amount of scoring
underneath it will be the most sinister
villain that you've ever seen but then
he also can be this like charismatic sex
symbol that you're just like yeah get it
like you know what i mean he does what
the other girls can't do like that's
just the best way to put it and and i
feel like nick cage and him both have
that very similar energy um and you need
to go check out some of matt's more like
i would say underground especially
european foreign language work like his
work in his native tongue to really i
think encompass that but lord is it good
yeah during the beginning of the
pandemic i binged hannibal and i was
like oh i'm seeing anything this guy
does after this
anything he puts out i want him he can
do a hannibal lecter and he could do
another round he can do the bad guy in
like grindelwald and doctor strange and
he could do this recent like one that he
did which is basically like ravenous set
in the danish wilderness like oh it's
the name of it it's uh it just came out
i'll look it up in a second but yeah no
it's it's that kind of energy and i
think that's why nicholas cage will
always be
and there's so many other examples of it
like sure you could have gotten mark
wahlberg to do national treasure but
mark wahlberg can't do mandy and there's
so many like you could take the action
stars that he does it better you can
take the more serious dramatic actors
that he does you could take the straight
up comedic weird stuff that he does with
stuff like adaptation or um
uh
matchstick men you know and you can also
look at something like like face off
because with face off him and john
travolta clearly had a ball imitating
each other but i still and and charles
is great in the movie but when travolta
becomes the villain of the film it's
like he's having fun as nick cage but
he's not he can't do that for an entire
movie and put it on his back the way
that that nick cage could and that was
again i mean you're talking about the
heyday of nick cage's an action star so
i remember being in the theater i don't
think i was even i think all my friends
were 16 and i and i didn't have a
driver's license yet and so
there was a discussion and and you know
don't do this in the theater kids just
focus on the movie you can stay out past
curfew but we were all sort of it was
like seven of us we're all debating how
much trouble
individually we're going to get in if we
miss curfew because we don't want to
leave the rock early because this movie
is just too much fun and so a couple
guys bolted me and two of my friends
didn't we did get in trouble but it was
worth it because we saw the rock and the
greatness that is the rock and then the
very next year you followed up with
conair which as as brandon and i feel
like jacqueline i believe you're on the
same page as us it's 55
rotten which is fresh adjacent but not
nearly fresh enough that movie is so
much fun even repeat viewing like if you
take it seriously it's an action movie
you can certainly look at elements of it
as a comedy but if you just take it
seriously as an action movie brandon
it's a great great 90s action flick as
amazing quotes put the bunny in back in
the box
but he always commits that's what's like
you know to jacqueline's point leonardo
could not do his twin role in an
adaptation like as charismatic and as
much as he's a leading man he could not
do the weirdness that's required there
even face-off when nicholas cage is
playing himself as a tortured john
travolta it's
it just chef's kiss you can't
i couldn't do that mentally as a
performer
and especially after he starts off so
crazy just dancing around to the madonna
video in that like this is what was so
crazy about the 90s they loved like
catholic iconography i remember this
very prevalent like romeo and juliet and
face off like they loved all of that
stuff and i was just like this is like
a weird look but hey everybody looks
like they're having fun i do also you
guys mention conair i have to mention
this one too about conair is what's
crazy about that one is like the heart
of that movie is still like
the family aspect of him and they're
like
when the diane warren penned first
leanne rhymes sang eventually trisha
yearwood's song saying uh how do i live
and he's walking with that torn beat-up
bunny the movie has to sell
when he hands her the bunny and it's
like i'm sorry i got it messed up like
it has to sell in that moment and he has
to be able to i think
solidify both and rock that really great
mullet hair because we haven't even
discussed nick cage hair because that's
a whole nother podcast episode yeah his
hair in that is is next level it's funny
bringing up the song that was that ended
up winning a grammy yeah how should i
live so
at first it was recorded by leanne rimes
she was 15 years old at the time and
then trisha yearwood covered it they
both released their version of the song
on the same day here's the rub leanne
rimes performed the song at the grammys
trisha yearwood's version ended up
winning at the grammys so nick cage is
giving everybody careers here
his movies are just a springboard for
everyone including as y'all alluded to
um just a great hairdressing team i do
agree with that also shout out to the
fact that um both diane warren lee and
rhymes and trash were put behind
basically some men who didn't like
things so the reason why trisha did her
recording is because the leanne rhymes
version which as you said was recorded
first was going to be the single the
producers of the movie which the song
was being pinned for we're like we don't
like her version
and the other little comedy of that is
her version because they didn't like her
version for
the movie right but the leanne version
was the hit
and leanne laughed that all the way to
the bank so i think they both win in a
certain way maybe i don't know i'm
definitely added to her spotify uh
paycheck because i listen to that song
probably once a week on shuffle
it's a good it's a good uh 90s like
action ballot yeah it's the perfect song
for any occasion and and if you're
looking at favorite scenes that are in
conair that there's there's so many to
choose from because you have used so
many great actors in that movie like
that's the thing that people forget
about conair is it it makes a great gif
and and and it's funny to reference it's
like clue for villains on a plane
because you have all these villains that
could end up being the main boss at any
point you got john malkovich on the
plane you got ving rhames on your plane
you got dave chappelle on your plane and
then down below you have uh cole meanie
you have john cusack jason everybody and
then obviously nicholas cage so brandon
what is the scene in conair that you're
like boom that's a great action movie
just the beginning when like he comes
back and he's like going to the bar
where uh monica pardoner's working and
like that whole scene is just cheesy and
then he gets to define that it's like
he's going to jail like oh yeah this is
going to be fun this is going to be a
fun ride but also obviously the ending
with like the fire truck chase through
vegas it's just so insane it did john
cusack's guys little motorcycle and i'm
like there's no way he would be able to
just jump on a motorcycle like that but
that's what you get from these action
movies
[Music]
his affinity
for filmmaking and just doing whatever
it takes to make the good movie i think
endears him to pretty much anyone and
that's the reason why like we have this
great quote from mark hoffmeyer talking
about nicholas cage from ethan hawk
where he's like i think he's one of the
few people in history of acting that's
really changed the form and i don't
think an actor like ethan hogg says that
unless he's seen him like put up the
goods and
i will always look at leaving las vegas
as the perfect example you made us fall
in love with somebody who literally is
killing themselves slowly over the
course of two and a half hours there's
something about nick cage who is just
he's he's he's in movies that give
female singers tremendous hits because
cheryl crow got a great one out of
leaving las vegas and that movie i mean
obviously that's a fresh movie 91 and
that's the movie he won his oscar for he
was also nominated for adaptation if we
go back to like the the things that
rotten tomatoes is wrong about
jacqueline do you have a movie that you
circle and you're like okay nick cage
needs more justice for this movie if i
had to circle the movie that nicholas
cage needs more justice for
i mean i think i'd go with probably gone
in 60 seconds just because that is
another one that is
hello rewatchable i've thought long days
about what it was like for vinnie jones
to be on the set of that movie set
like legitimately i've spent a
significant amount of time because that
was like angelina jolie was like still
wearing billy bob thornton's blood and
stuff
at that point nick cage is doing nick
cage i don't know what del roy linda was
probably thinking on the set of that
movie like it just seems like it was a
weird group of people giovanni ravisi
who if folks don't know about his
history he's got a few
there's a lot so yeah i would say gone
in 60 seconds that movie is hilary
watchable great soundtrack it's cars
i love movies about cars the fact that
the car is a character in that movie is
just so great i love love love it and
it's funny as hell so i would say
it's 25 rotten we we get another
all-time great nicholas cage character
name with that one brandon he plays
randall memphis reigns
and the dude first of all the thing that
sold me on gone in 60 seconds i remember
being in the theater i might have been
in the theater for face-off i can't
remember but
there was a trailer like a teaser
trailer for a new nick cage movie called
it's gone to 60 seconds and the trailer
was counting down from 60 seconds and
it's like and and basically the movie
theater was telling you that in the time
it took you to get your popcorn get a
drink and find your seats your car has
been stolen so it made everybody panic
for the rest of whatever the feature was
because we're just thinking oh
somebody's got two nick cages stealing
cars in 60 seconds i got to sit through
this thing for two hours before i go
check on my car to see if it's still
parked in the garage my honda civic
there's no way it's still gonna be there
i love it it's pretty
pretty intense advertising
thinking about the 60 seconds though i
was like
i don't know if i would have liked that
i don't know if i would have watched the
movie afterwards because i'm too
paranoid greatest premise though because
it's 50 i think you got to steal 50 cars
in a night or something like that yeah
yeah
it's i mean
there's nothing more fun and doing some
some like reading on the making of that
movie
nicholas gage loves driving to the point
where the some of the like like i guess
the the insurance folks saw some of the
dailies and the next day they were on
set because they wanted to make sure
that nick cage wasn't doing too much
driving but brandon you feel it in the
that movie is just like it's one fast
car chase and i i think that you could
see that and you could say all right
fast and furious wishes it was that the
first movie does and then from that fast
and furious folks like this is where our
franchise goes yep i mean god is 60
seconds i remember seeing that in the
movie theater with some friends
um and i i had a huge question angelina
jolie ever since uh
was it hackers that came out in the mid
90s so i i was going to see him for that
nicholas cage wasn't the big draw for me
at that point even though like i like
the rock and face off and stuff so i
went for angelia jolie i liked giovanni
we were bc because i was a fan of him
starting with boiler room and then
saving private ryan and so i'm just like
okay these are a lot of people i like uh
chai mcbride who was on uh boston public
at the time i was a fan of him and he
has a great line in this where uh
the the young black actor who like
played the gangster that was part of the
crew he was like oh you look like a
ghetto smurf i remember like laughing at
that uh that joke even as like a
teenager yeah um but yeah like the the
movie is just
it's just anchored by nicholas cage
in this like i'm trying to save my
little brother but this this plan
doesn't make any sense that this guy is
definitely going to kill us at the end
evan angelia jolene him with their they
don't even have chemistry it's just like
they're both
kind of hot people talking to each other
this weird movie it's it's it's a while
it's a wild time
all right so i'm looking at at the nic
cage resume because i want to be
generous i want to let you all have your
nic cage movies that are rotten that
should be fresh and i'm looking at what
what's left and there's still so many to
pick from folks so i have one that that
might surprise people a little bit
because it's not nicholas cage action
centric
it's not captain curly's mandolin sorry
everyone one of my maybe my favorite
nick cage movie that is rotten that
definitely deserves to be fresh is an
underrated
christmas movie and that would be the
family man
where he plays a guy who it's
he he wakes up and and he's super
wealthy but he's he's he's alone and
he's lonely just works all the time so
it's sort of like a modern day kind of
like mix of it's a wonderful wife and
he's got a little bit of an ebenezer
scrooge to him and then don cheadle is
sort of his angel and swaps him with the
life that he could have had had he
stayed with his college sweetheart and
they started a family together so the
next day he wakes up and it's christmas
morning and all of a sudden taylor owns
his wife he's got kids he's got a dog
he's got neighbors and this is his just
mundane suburban life and he's trying to
fight it for so long and then we go
through the movie and the movie is what
the movie is but it's only 53
jaclyn am i
crazy for thinking this movie is super
fresh is this is this not a fresh movie
in your eyes it's not that it's not a
fresh movie in my eyes i just know that
i don't have
the same kind of love
and affection you do for it it's not
getting to god
it gets to go full nick cage in it but
the youtube clips will be there without
me having to sit through the rest
sorry does that mean i think it was me
it's very insulting to my movie brandon
are you going to pile on i yeah i can't
agree with that man like uh i think
the the other performances kind of
brought it down for me i remember taylor
who i was a fan of i remember like i
wasn't a fan of that performance i
thought the movie also like even as a
teenager i was like this feels
manipulative like i don't feel like this
is genuine these feelings i'm supposed
to have about the character i think that
that's why
like i i can't i can't jump on the bus
with you man it's an easy manipulation
like i get it like and no offense mark
maybe it hits you different nowadays
nick cage when he wakes up the first
time and i'm happy
yeah and maybe you're like well maybe
you're sleeping back thinking about
who's who would be my ta leone
well that's the problem though is that
because you know how my brain works
jacqueline so every time i watch that
movie i think okay i don't want to wake
up i mean it'd be nice to wake up next
to you know his wife but then you
realize oh no i procreated oh god and so
as much as that might suck then he
he's got the dog and so if you give me
the dog versus my my other wife where
i'm wealthy but i don't have a dog
that's where i i just i i love watching
that movie because i don't know which
decision i'm making at the end of the
day i don't know if i'm going back
disappointing don cheadle by the way i
also don't want to get on his bad side
but i'd be disappointing don cheeto if i
went back to my wealthy life but then
i'm maybe my disappointing myself
because i'm going back to my family
which i never wanted to start
it's a real conundrum as i'm looking at
molly the wonder dog giving me the eyes
i love it i love it hey look being
conflicted about it is probably the best
way to be at this point okay any any
pushback on either one of the national
treasures being rotten because i think
that's a crime against humanity i think
the first one definitely should be fresh
absolutely that's the first one's a lot
of fun it goes it's one of his
more brisk action films it goes through
very quickly and also has john boyt
who's also cuckoo bananas so
it's just
it's just a lot of fun and it's also
like if you it's a better version than
the venture coat yeah i mean that's not
saying much though
yeah but if we go if if we're looking at
like the genre of these movies all want
to be the next indiana jones i think
that like he's talk about angelina jolie
the tomb raiders are in the conversation
the new tomb raider is in the
conversation tom holland running around
with mark wahlberg and uncharted is now
in the conversation you have those
brendan frazier mummy movies i'll take
national treasure over all of them
because nick cage again gets to
sometimes be crazy but also show that
he's grounded but then we also get the
stellar comedic relief of justin bartha
who is the unsung hero of both of those
movies his lines are so so good sean
bean's a villain come on that's a great
family adventure movie uh yes absolutely
and uh if i believe was one of the first
films that started the trend of sean
bean dying in popular things
right like he had died in other things
before that but this set the trend
because he died in golden eye
first but like this was where it was
like you know you need to like do it
three times before you realize it's not
a mistake that was like the third time
we're like this is not a mistake they
just like killing this fool yeah laura
the rings fellowship with the ring and
then you get to eventually game of
thrones you're just like jesus sean
who's your representation
yeah that's right golden eye lord of the
rings and then by the time we get to
national treasure like this dude just
likes to die national treasure is 46
national treasure book of secrets the
sequel is it 36 and if you want more on
why maybe we didn't get another uh
national treasure movie jacqueline and i
had our guest from new york times on
marlo stern about a year ago jack and
we've been we're getting long in the
tooth with this thing but we were
talking other nick cage movies and he
basically broke down that like after the
second national treasure movie nick cage
was already interested in these weird
antiquities and like going all over the
world looking for dinosaur bones and
stuff he was looking for the holy grail
brandon i don't know if you know any of
this he was looking for the holy grail
and he ended up in vermont he was very
close and for some reason his map led
him to vermont now as a guy who's in new
york i think it's safe to say that the
holy grail is nowhere near new england
no no no
honestly i just
appreciate the tars for him trying it
takes a certain level of arrogance and
stupidity to be like you know what i'm
getting it
i think that's what he does though i
think he figures it out he doesn't say
no to a project and i think like he'll
just read a script blindly like that
he's agreed to by his agent and be like
yeah i'll figure this out oh it's
supposed to play a lizard man sure
listen man running a diner in minnesota
yup i can make this work i did i dig it
i dig it i did everyone a a favor today
um because full disclosure recently i
got to do more nic cage research because
i was doing for my show versus which you
can watch on peacock um i it was bruce
willis versus nicholas cage and so you
know going through box office and tomato
meter and all these things and the
deciding round i decided to watch a
movie from both bruce willis and nick
cage's library that are zero percent
on the tomato meter literally zero
percent and so the one that i chose for
nick cage is a movie called left behind
if you haven't seen left behind
it's just
it's it's a million things that are so
ridiculously stupid but it is so much
fun and that's one of the reasons why i
took nick cage over bruce willis to win
that versus spoil alert is just because
he goes for it and he can do more things
like we're talking about earlier than
what bruce willis can so i guess my
question is what's like the worst nick
cage movie you all have ever seen what's
the movie where you said that movie's
terrible maybe nick cage was good in it
but like the worst nick cage movie for
me it would be snake eyes
i think like there was just nothing on
that move in that movie for me to grab
and i saw in the movie theater because
again my mom used to take me to r rated
movies and then she wonders why i'm all
cool i'm taking you to see guys she was
out of control um
i just remember like not caring like
it's spoiler alert gary sinise is the
bad guy and i was like oh lieutenant
dan's the bad guy like i couldn't see
that a mile away because he has snake
eyes and it's just like i don't like
this movie it was it's bill i don't know
how long it is i think it's a little
over two hours and it felt like it like
i just couldn't wait for it to be over
the worst movie nick cage ever made is
the death of superman the one that he
was supposed to make with kevin smith
that they never made and that's the
worst because it didn't get made and i
still hear about it every single time
that is the one that i i will say is the
worst because
it should have been made and it's a
travesty
if nothing else for the fact that i
think it would have made batman who'da
made superman returns look like a
masterwork like i have a feeling we
escaped the worst b movie ever in
existence but it would have been funny
and you know uh you know the story
behind like this he wanted to spy john
peters was producing he wanted a spider
and then it ended up going to wawa west
like there's so much craziness around
that movie and nicholas cage and the
test suit with the mullet he has another
mullet as clark kent and it is
uh you're absolutely right jacqueline
brandon i want you to do me a favor i
want you to complete this sentence if
nick cage stars in
superman lives
all the box office records are broken
i mean like this was before we really
knew what we were doing with comic book
movie franchises we knew how to make a
standalone christopher reeve had done it
michael keaton did it with batman but we
weren't really in these shared universes
yet is there a chance that superman
lives does that for us or do you think
that that's just like a one-off superman
movie because if it does well you know
we're getting a sequel with even more
crazy john peters creations if we got if
we had gotten superman lives and it was
huge and then we got sequels we would
not have the comic movies we have now
that's the thing it would it would
literally change cinematic history if
that happened um
i think it would have been worse than
the star wars special from 1978 i'm
sorry like
it would have been bad i just have no
faith that would have been a good movie
he didn't even look good in the middle
you don't think it would have been
entertaining
and like first of all
for some reason he's wearing that like
that like con air hair but it's dyed jet
black
in the suit fitting that's in schnepp's
movie like it's just like
i think everyone got out of that one
alive
i mean i say the same thing about the
george miller justice league because um
the guy that was gonna play
batman i think and that one has
basically been cut out of the
promotional materials in the last two
movies he's made so yeah yeah that would
have been a very different justice
league as well too so like i don't know
but i'm i'm not i'm not saying that
everyone in it didn't want to make a
good movie i'm saying at that time they
just did not have the manpower to do it
i i think though the world being robbed
of tim burton and nicholas cage working
together on the movie though more than
warrants potentially going in a time
machine and making this happen don't
disagree
don't disagree and that was tim burton
at his prime so i will have effort that
tim burton is great
but
i want to see the movie i i think that's
one of those movies where whether it's
great or whether it's terrible we do
want to make sure that we get to see it
at some point we never will but it's
just one of those like alternate
universe if i if i put you in a
multiverse and you can go see all these
other movies that that if what if
richard gere had said yes to die hard
before bruce willis got a chance or what
if nicolas cage ended up being superman
what if christopher walken ended up
getting cast as the original superman or
han solo something like that i think
that superman lives is up there with a
movie that we would all want to go see
and nick cage has proven once again with
pig that he still has a lot of that
great actor in him he's got a couple
movies coming out later this year so
brandon i want to talk to you about your
podcast medium popcorn but before we get
there just as a final word favorite nick
cage movie of all time regardless of
tomato meter anything else favorite nick
cage movie of all time
is
what
oh that's that's tough okay i'm going
with the wicker man just because he's
going wicked there's so many sound bites
in moments that i just i i'm thinking
about dropping my jaw down just thinking
about them i mean when he's in a bear
costume it just starts punching people
and he's running and he still gets
caught and then they torture him and
then you see the digital bees and him
and you realize how he had to react
with digital bees stinging him and
it's just
it's so much fun
if you embrace through nicholas cages
and what he brings to the table it is
just so much fun it's like a warm
blanket
jacqueline you're fake not gonna go that
far
um my favorite nic cage movie of all
time
i guess i i mean i guess it says
something about my twisted nature but i
guess leaving uh leaving las vegas i
really do
i really do love leaving las vegas it is
twisted he does go full cage in that
movie just a different kind of full cage
uh yeah i really i love him in that um
pig is up there as well for me as well
uh also mandy mandy is up there for me
as well so yeah mandy is yeah it's
mandy's one of those movies where like i
can't recommend it to all my friends but
like if you know your friend well enough
and you think they're gonna like manny
they end up raving about it so mandy's
up there for me i'm not gonna put mandy
as like my favorite favorite nic cage
movie raising arizona is a contender and
that was one of the first movies where
we got to see nick cage because
basically when when he signed on to do
that movie the coen brothers sort of let
him do what he wanted to do and i think
that he was quoted as saying that he was
just trying to basically be the human
version of woody woodpecker right down
to the hair and to their credit the cohn
brothers were like cool dude run with it
i i think my favorite nick cage movie of
all time is still going to be the rock i
just think it's the it's it's one of the
great action movies of all time but i
will give a major shout to uh to raising
arizona as well brandon i do want to
give two honorable mentions though kick
ass
he was phenomenal in that first one yeah
he was awesome yeah and then there's
this movie in the early 90s it could
happen to you with bridget fonda
yeah i used to watch all the time like
i'm a sucker for like romantic comedies
and i believe rosie perez was in it too
and i just yep yeah like you know being
a young boy
stanley tucci's in that one as well too
yeah i just uh sucker and also my family
used to do this thing where like every
week they would they would play the
lottery and the way i guess to maybe not
think that they were degenerates they
were like hey brandon you know if we win
this lottery we're gonna buy a new house
and all these things i'm like oh cool
and then in this movie nicholas cage won
the lottery now saw all the good things
he was doing was like if i win the
lottery i'm going to be like nicholas
cage minus being a cop
we all think we're going to be generous
with our lottery money until we see the
winning numbers and then oh good things
but i mean i i maybe if one of us wins
the lottery we should finance a nic cage
movie just because we'd all have such a
good time doing it i don't disagree and
hey listen uh
it's
he has a similar model to what bruce
does which is basically if you can get
him out in a couple of days he'll do it
and he's like
he'll knock out those scenes over a week
and then make the movie around him and
there's your uh you know cut print ship
and then every so often he can crank out
another oscar contender like what we saw
with pigs so um
brandon i'm not gonna give all the
credit to nic cage for you starting your
your podcast where you you talk movies
you review movies you review some some
old movies maybe some cult classics that
people have missed what was sort of the
uh the inspiration behind starting
medium popcorn and why not go large
popcorn
yeah so um i i started the podcast
actually by myself but then i realized
very quickly it's lonely to podcast and
talk about movies just by yourself and
so my friend justin he and i had done
sketch comedy we met in college we known
each other for years and
i already like had experience podcasting
and was like hey man like you know we
can vibe about anything we could talk
about anything that comes up like let's
do this together and we create a theme
song and that's kind of what start like
gave us the
idea of be like oh we have something
here so folks medium popcorn i i will
say has the best theme song on any
podcast it's a cover of easy lover by
phil collins it's fantastic check it out
um but yeah like the the idea was just
for us to essentially be like friends
talking about whatever movies we felt
like reviewing and that's what a lot of
people that follow us and support us
they say it's like being my group of
friends hearing them talk about the
movies and sometimes they share the same
feelings i have and sometimes they're
completely off-base but i still enjoy
the conversation and we do go down some
weird rabbit holes um especially when we
talk about like insane films like
anything nicholas cage um you know we
always have a lot of fun doing that or
just anything that has like absurd
moments or uh clearly like you know
there's a string shoestring budget and
so we talk about hey like we know what
the filmmakers are trying to do because
we've been on sets before we're actors
but then also
you know they kind of dropped the ball
here in post or something like that so
uh yeah but we do new and old films it's
always a variety there's no specific
theme so it keeps uh us and the
listeners on their toes i dig it jaclyn
you uh you should probably at some point
check out medium popcorn to see what
they have to say about the nic cage
movies that are coming up that you've
already seen that you are being very
tight-lipped about
not very tight-lipped about probably
gonna get in trouble we're gonna have to
have a conversation with brian perez to
make sure i don't get banned from seeing
movies ever again but
very excited either way all right well
that is medium popcorn and again is that
your snack when you go to the movies
because i'm i'm i'm a very
traditionalist i'm a popcorn i might do
a little bit of butter if i'm feeling
frothy but i'll i'll get a diet beverage
of some sort and a popcorn and i'm good
to go i think medium is also uh the
reason why we chose that size because
that's usually the average rating for
the most part for a lot of our phones
but also like that's the healthiest
option we both concluded in regards to
getting the media in the medium because
if you go large or
beyond that you might have some problems
or people might look at you sideways so
medium across the way
don't take it something about holding
that bucket jacqueline what were you
calling me out for my yeah
i hate that you're a purist of popcorn
because i've explained to you how no
butter jalapenos and parmesan cheese is
the way to go and every time i mention
that to you you think i'm crazy but
small popcorn with jalapenos it's better
for you
brand new look too a little bit of
parmesan cheese it is popcorn nachos not
on my popcorn uh like on nachos i used
to work at the movie theater that was my
first job ever actually was in the movie
theater and my favorite thing besides
popcorn would be the melted you know
movie theater cheese and then some
jalapenos especially if they were like
freshly cut jalapenos almost yes not the
softy ones yeah queso it was my
introduction to queso and and it was
when i saw batman 1989 and my entire
world changed my athletic career might
have taken a dip but my entire
movie-going career would never be the
same and none of us would ever be the
same after seeing any of those great
nick cage movies that we just talked
about so once again he is brandon
collins you can check out his podcast
wherever you enjoy podcast how you're
listening to us you can listen to him on
medium popcorn or check out and
subscribe to his youtube channel so you
can see him and justin talk all things
new movies old movies things that you
missed it's it's just it's a great
endeavor you're doing and uh it it
reminds me of a bygone show called
shmo's know and uh keep on keep on
carrying the torch my man and uh we we
love to have you on the show appreciate
it thank you all so much for having me
on any time to talk about mr cage it's
always a good time
[Music]
it was so much fun talking with brandon
getting to connect with him and we
really find that we see eye to eye on
most of these nic cage action movies
you're gone in 60 seconds you're you're
face-offs obviously conair the rock but
then jaclyn and brandon both just
leaving me high and dry with family man
maybe you know what i'll watch it again
to christmas and maybe i'll see if i'm
wrong but pretty sure i'm right on that
one so simon west as i tease at the top
the director of conair got his start
doing some commercials but he also did a
very famous music video that you've
definitely seen usually when you didn't
want to
sorry to rickroll everyone he directed
the video for rick astley never going to
give you up so i apologize for the
earworm but it's going to be in your
head the rest of the week again
my bad but if you want something good
then you can check out rotten tomatoes
that's wrong particularly coming up when
we do our hook episode we are so excited
to talk about hook it's been one of
these bonanza episodes that we've wanted
to do for a long time it's one of the
very few spielberg directed movies
that's rotten on his tomato meter resume
and if you want us to do hook send us a
video recording of you telling us why
you love hook why you think ride
tomatoes got hooked right it can run the
gamut of suggestions but i know that
there's a lot of hook defenders out
there one of them may not be talking
right now but you can email us anytime
whether it's about hooker any other
mailbag you want to get to us you have
thoughts about what movies we should be
talking about coming up here on the show
to hit us up but rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com subscribe rate review
do all that great stuff and on behalf of
jacqueline coley our special guest
brandon collins producee lucy and our
esteemed engineer brian perez i am
merely mark ellis saying thanks for
watching you can get upcoming comedy
tickets for where i'm on tour at mark
ellis dot live and we'll see you next
time right here on rotten tomatoes is
wrong
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you